hey guys how's it going so if you can't
tell I am not in my kitchen where are we
right now we're on the man about cake
set now can you tell me a little bit
about your show for people who have no
idea yes every Tuesday we bring the
coolest cakes ever to YouTube and they
are so cool so if you guys don't know I
originally found you because I was on my
sister's Channel and we're making a
video and I was talking about how cool
your cakes were and I told you guys to
tweet him to come to my house and I can
take with me and guess what it happened
I did know it was super fun a Nintendo
switch cake it was amazing to do
guessing me too and now I'm here on your
set and I thought before we get into the
questions ask you guys for some
questions which was probably a mistake
because I said make them cake related
and you got a lot I get what everyone
says what's the best cake you've ever
made so there's like hundreds of those
you can talk about that but look explore
the set a little bit yes take a peek so
right now we have this beautiful party
themed and do you know why because today
is my birthday tomorrow is Joshua's
birthday so we are having a great
celebration
so what else we have here so these are
just some of my favorite cake plate yet
look at my school have to have something
creepy always because I make beautiful
case all the time so something creepy
what's that I love right oh that's
collected you're missing one and I'm
missing one yeah I so I was cutting out
fondant for a cake that I made you and I
use this as a toilet well I just kind of
went like that that works use an edge up
puts fun we'll put that back what are
some jars of stuff I get sprinkles and
this is my pantry so I'm so sorry I hope
those are not special
are these do you actually use them as a
set I use them oh and then we have this
because you're here just in case so we
kind of do adjusting this coming because
it's our birthday we both made cakes on
his channel if you guys wanna check it
out man about cake I will put a link in
the description so we both made each
other cakes her birthday what surprise
so at this point we have already seen
both of our cakes and guys I almost
cried when I saw the cake did you really
yes there was so much fun it was so so
incredible
I don't think I can fly back with it
do you think TSA would be a little upset
with that I'm not sure that that will
fit in a quart size or syllable plastic
have you flown with a cake that big
before I have actually never fallen with
a cake I've flown with pieces of cake
but they were like all wrapped up and
then I checked them you checked that you
put the cake in there's there's ways
yeah
PR boxes into boxes and then it comes
out over there by where the skis come
out interest this is like the the big
bulky item yes that's where I go well
we've got some questions from you guys
let's take a look this is interesting
speaking of knives somebody suffers joy
causes with knives yes they are Nintendo
switch joy con knife blade holder pretty
sure you need this okay well that's not
a question that was just something so
Kevin wants to know what was our biggest
fail in the kitchen biggest fell in the
kitchen you go first
oh well where do we start I don't think
we have that much time there was the
home pod cake there was the wedding cake
there was my Valentines cake jeez let's
just fill in the blades that steak
wasn't bad oh you mean he saw last
year's I don't know if I've had like a
really of course he doesn't have any
because your cakes are perfect and
beautiful I read I have I've had times
where people other people mess my cakes
up so what you're saying then I had to
go had we gonna fix them so it was not
your fault it was not my fault okay I
went to a wedding and I really wanted to
make the wedding cake and the person
said no their friend had was already
gonna do it we're sitting there the
ceremony's about to start and a mom
comes over and says we need your help
and I go into the reception hall and the
cake is a mess and the girl is crying
and I help to save the cake but we
literally went outside and cut flowers
and did the best we could
gotcha so that was probably it was
probably like the most panicked I was
like let's get this cake together but it
was not my fault not his fault so
basically what he's saying is he's
perfect and doesn't make mistakes I will
take all the cake Macias for you so this
is interesting Tom wants to know is
carrot cake a real cake or just a
vegetable in disguise it's that's a good
question because I mean I feel like any
time I've had carrot cake there's the
little chunks of carrot in it so carrots
actually have a lot of sugar in them
really yeah and so it gives a lot of
structure to the cake it kind of
it's like having zucchini bread
something like that so it's more of like
a savory cake like say a marinara sauce
right here I care so that kit makes it
sweeter makes little sweeter yeah yeah
this is all new information to me
honestly anything good that I do on any
of my cooking videos I've learned from
you a row because you guys are pros will
have to do a video where I come over and
cook you and your sister dinner yes I
can I can cook like groceries like
really well sure I would sorry that's
such a southern thing I can Coker she's
know I went to culinary school so I
learned how to like butcher chickens and
stuff like that oh my goodness um I was
on chopped and we tell you how fast I
got chopped really okay they're like I
wouldn't even go on chopped it's
stressful wait here's a potato and a
stick make dinner I'm like I'm out yeah
it's crazy I mean what do you do with
these things especially coming from a
background of zero cooking I mean I post
mates breakfast so you did the blue
apron thing right that was did that
really boot doesn't matter I wanted a
buddy that looked really good I was
impressed it's a blue apron I can almost
handle cuz it's basically done for you
hi is asking will you bake your iMac pro
of cake every year on its arrival day Oh
an iMac Pro baked goods that to be like
standing up something you should think
about is there like really thin right I
mean I've seen you do some crazy things
okay thank you back up to rig it we'd
have to yeah there might be some rice
cereal treats in that one frog is asking
are you going to make a cake shaped like
Maddie's head for his birthday
you should witness his birthday well
obviously like I mean I don't want to do
a spoiler or anything for your video
watch what guys don't watch uh yeah you
have to see the cake that he made for me
it's so impressive may or may not have
Matty on it may or may not have him I
also have 45 pictures of her dog on my
phone currently I have hundreds and
thousands you should have let me know I
could have started sharing problem water
you want you to know what I was doing
where were the missing air pods that you
lost and now they're found they were in
a secret compartment in my purse I was
so sad well I've already lost one pair
and then I got a replacement pair and
then I got a backup parents the
replacement because they were so hard to
get and I knew I was gonna do this today
just sew a little pocket and your purse
that says earbuds and then well it kind
of was in that pocket but I didn't know
who's there so yes I found them so so
far I've only lost one pair of ear pods
those things are great who has better
capes Justine or Josh mahjongg capes
Isis cakes are so amazing like what was
your favorite cake that you've made so
far in the show probably the octopus
cake that was really cool
just because I had a dream about that
cake years ago I dreamt that I made that
but I couldn't justify making it just
for the you know just to make it cuz I'm
at the time so I had a friend who had a
nautical wedding and she loves octopi
and I sketched it out she was like
that's my wedding cake yes so so
obviously I got to practice by making it
for her and then we made it on the show
love it and James's wedding cake oh
speaking of James um somebody here asked
how many pairs of shoes does James have
Marcus wants to know why is that we
never see the faces of the beloved
hashtag man about faces
hi he's Brandon James is back there on
the ones and twos DJing this is Tommy
hello and then culinary producer Lisa
she's mulling about cake
they're so awesome well guys here it is
well that's really all the questions
because everyone is just asking what's
the coolest cake you've made or what's
your biggest fails so why don't we say
what should we do next
yes I guess I mean I'm in LA a lot this
is your first time I'm here right in
Denver I'm gonna lay a lot under so
you'll have to go this floor to this
yeah yeah so next time out a minute I'm
out in LA we'll figure out a time to
cool let's cook something please let's
do it guys what would you like to see us
make together and make give me anything
and it should make us we try to make an
iMac like it's not a little aggressive
it scares me maybe I could think I could
figure it out okay you think it maybe
one have to be a cake with like it an
iMac on it made out of pasta Yas or
something like that if you think you
just take your iMac and put it on top of
it we could be good look how good we are
don't cut into that well you guys have
any suggestions for things that you
would like to see us make please please
please leave them in the comments below
and I think we should go celebrate our
birthday now yes we have cake to eat we
do oh so good make sure you guys go
subscribe to Joshua's channel man about
cake it is the best I love it so thank
you yes well thanks for having me like
destroy your kitchen because this is
something that oh this is everyday yeah
okay good bye
[Music]